you know like when you go to a new you
go to a new state like you were just in
Utah like you never really feel like
you're in a different place until you
see like their local commercials so when
we went to go to Arizona two weeks ago
there was a commercial on the television
I actually thought it was like SNL or
some sketch [ __ ] that was supposed to be
funny but there was a commercial for a
website called farmersonly.com and it's
a dating site specifically if you're
looking for a farmer or a cowboy or it's
just that yeah and the whole commercials
like are you looking for somebody who's
and it sounds [ __ ] absurd but it's
like what have we come to well I mean
people have specific desires some people
like people who you know far farm okay
so if you had a site come on all right I
like people that farm I get it east
meets east or whatever but if you had a
site that was gonna cater to what you
want like what you look for in a person
what would it be called
oh [ __ ] like what's the log line of them
yeah this one is farmersonly.com we're
only dating farmers mine would be half
anything with a [ __ ] pad no have
Egyptian half Filipino oh that's great
your search is three people people that
can swim good yeah and women that I love
that also farm that also farm sometimes
what would be George would you I'd go
rich Poor's cuz I like people who would
like live rich and poor like I like that
mix of like being able to like be
outdoorsy hang out outside but also like
you can live the good life too so you
would call it rich poor calm yeah or it
whatever set you're on I would recommend
women women if they see George's provel
to swipe right yeah because he's not
gonna be able to close the deal anyway
get a free meal out of it
get a stove analogy yeah you'll get a
free meal and maybe some eggs make out
with you you always pay for the meal on
your first date George um it's a mix I
feel it out
really yeah I every [ __ ] time first
time every time
you really like her and it was it was a
hit no it's completely mix it's like
whatever I mean I'm not I don't care
either way even if it was a gargoyle I
would just pay once once that's it and
then because I don't you know it's a
nice thing to do there was one girl that
insisted on paying on the first date and
then like if she did that then I'd be
like oh she's a and then like she was
she was kind of great I didn't text her
for two days yeah and then she was like
hey why haven't you texted me oh that's
[ __ ] though she reversed it under she
pulled the George she got real mad like
and got weird okay well you're welcome
for the free beer for the free day oh my
I was kind of riding crazy crazy signs
when we uh when we went out that's whoa
I was ready to pay that like but like if
I'd paid sistah Don paying it would have
been like a yeah I'm not I really don't
like you I didn't want to say it to her
face I would say it's her face hey oh my
goodness I I'm kind of them sometimes
sorry in the beginning I would probably
be okay with paying the girl I took on a
day before I did on you and yeah you
went on a lot of dates a couple you're
my first and only hustle you only on to
burn more rubber I should have really
maximized my tender experience I should
have like gone on would I break up for a
year ago get your soul your lowitz and
come back in here no because I'm also
your Oates calm
no it's over two loads I already have
like [ __ ] horizontal necklines it's
over for me and dating of course it's my
necklines B's I'm gonna say this right
now Ilana if you were if I were to die
or you wanted to leave you you would be
in a relationship within a month with
George with me you think so oh yeah how
dare you say that that hurts my feelings
no yeah I'm just saying that's how
pretty you are
oh I thought you meant like I'm a
[ __ ] heartless [ __ ] after a month
after you died if you died Bobby
oh no if I died and I'm in heaven and a
month in you're like hanging out with
some other dude don't talk to me when
you're in heaven because I'm gonna be
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] that really hurt
me after wait a year right do you think
after death you have to wait a year no
there's no [ __ ] timeline for we go
back to being our luck like if you died
three months I can see myself coined
like if Ari Shaffir good let's go to
Thailand just [ __ ] positives
I'd be like as well yeah if I'm in
heaven looking down I'd be like dude
like how about it live your life I
wouldn't want you to hold back your
happiness because you think that that's
what that's respect yeah but you would
do [ __ ] like while he's [ __ ] a girl
in Thailand you appear as a ghost as the
face of the girl
it would be like that one Michelle
Pfeiffer movie what's that would you
would you be more shocked if you died
and I was dating either
I was [ __ ] either George or Gilbert
shocking it would shock me if you
actually touched George in that way
because you're not into the one you're
trying to say that me Bobby I mean it
would be it not as shocking it would be
like yeah I guess my [ __ ] if I was
seeing him every time you say oh you're
pretty much to me like a piece of wood
you're like when I look at you I look at
like a light fixture or like that's a
you know concrete like nothing there's
nothing sexual about an ottoman there's
nothing sexual about you like I would
never [ __ ] you even if it was like us to
on stranded Island and we live forever
on this island I thought would see you
walk twice just hang on what's up George
and then I'll just be on my side of the
island
we're never sneaky you give me time I
can sneak in you know you rape me then
you know we got that's another [ __ ]
game that's a whole other thing
[Music]